Yeah,
I have an obsession basically with power and money is power and you don't have a
platform without that and then it calls us when he wants to commit suicide.
Now you're going to get worn out.
I'll tell you.
That's a dangerous sir.
Yeah.
Okay.
The wall with the x one,
it can,
I have all of my high income folks and on the other side,
yeah.
I think the opposite side judges me to the side that I stand on it.
Yeah,
there is.
There is judgment.
Society seems to think that it's based on mental conditions,
alcohol abuse or drug abuse that we're in the streets where most of the times
it's not.
I do feel judged by the other side because I feel like most people have an
innate massive in or insecurity within themselves as they start as human beings.
So jealousy is a natural tendency mass majority of people have.
Sure.
And that's the root of why they're not successful to begin with.
I don't think jealousy is natural.
All I think we were all born exactly the same and to say it's inherited I think
is a bunch of bs.
It's all learned behavior and I'm telling you,
if we took these people on that side and they were trained to have different
beliefs and judgments,
they'd be a wealthy as hell.
Every human being incredible from the start.
That's a beautiful sight.
Disagrees.
I Dunno.
I guess I don't really spend that much time around people who are on the other
side,
so I don't feel like I didn't know what they actually think about me.
There's enough open minded people that do really well.
There was very kind and so I don't feel like the other site judgment.
Yeah,
I would spend a day on the other side.
I sort of started on the other aisle.
I grew up sort of low income neighborhoods,
broken homes,
but for me that was something that kind of gave me that drive to want to achieve
and to me I would say that that's been something that's been very helpful to me.
So yeah,
I just like to see what it's like to be on the other side.
For once I would say,
yeah,
I would like to learn from them.
I would help my mother,
but it depends on whether we're doing,
if it's illegal or if it's something my conscience that will step back.
I don't know how they got their money.
Yeah,
you don't.
Once you update and financial security,
whatever that means to you as individuals,
you realize it's all for nothing.
It says it in the Bible ever live.
I live in Hebrew.
It means it's all for nothing.
The reality of why we do all we do is because we're looking to feel fulfilled
and that's why I have no problem going back because fulfillment doesn't come
from money.
I was scared to admit how much money I made.
Yeah.
A lot of times have you speak how much money you make.
That's a great way to get sued and let people know you have something to get it.
So sometimes it's better off to not let people know what you got.
Okay.
I cut the realization that wait a minute,
I'm supposed to work so hard in life to get a job.
Two,
married a woman who wouldn't marry me if I didn't have that job.
So that's why I look at a lot of my pharmacist friends,
[inaudible] friends.
Uh,
they boast this and that,
but I asked him a question,
if you didn't have that money in that job,
would she still be with you?
She wouldn't.
So,
so,
um,
I'm never afraid to tell you what,
how much?
100%.
Yeah.
If someone really loves you,
it was always enough.
If someone doesn't know will never be enough.
And so I'm not just tell people how much I make my whole life and that also weed
out all the people I want.
No part of.
Most of my friends were true friends are the best time we ever have or like
simple conversation like this money is,
do you feel like money is power?
Yeah.
And I've seen it and what way
in the illegal ways
I've seen it too.
It does,
it works.
It is manifested power.
Is there a higher power or is there a higher spiritual level?
Certainly,
but in the level that we operate in,
um,
yeah,
I mean if you want to get something done,
you need some sort of financial backing.
You know,
generally speaking,
money is energy.
It's,
that's all it is,
right?
So on form it is power.
It's power to be used in a good way about what the views and a bad way.
Money will only amplify who you are as a person.
To a larger extent,
you're a Douche bag.
You're going to be a big a douchebag.
You're a sweetheart of a person giving you again,
become more of a giving human beings.
That's all that money is going to do.
Might be a good idea to go talk to Gandhi.
Yeah,
you want
to talk to mother Theresa.
The thing about power is you speak something and it occurs.
Do you speak something and does it happen?
And if you've gotten money or if you don't have money,
it's basically the bottom line is this,
what is my purpose in life and am I boom having it happen.
All you gotta do is look at somebody's life,
can look at people's Auras.
All of us haven't certain worry.
It's real obvious.
Sure.
And you know whether you're making a difference in that you can't fool him.
I am satisfied with how much money I have right now.
Once you attain financial security.
And I said this earlier,
it's just access for me.
I'm a 31.
I probably mentioned financial security when I was like 2110 years ago.
Self made no daddy,
no mommy,
nobody.
And I was very fortunate to recognize what success means.
That responsibility of success and also what I want out of life.
Money doesn't motivate me anymore.
I didn't come here today to show off that I have money.
I came here because hopefully I learned something that I didn't know yesterday
and that I also could hope maybe influence someone that didn't know something
the same
being wealthy is having no once.
Yeah,
I think I've got just about everything I need.
I'm,
I'm telling you to have a lot more.
Don't need it.
Well,
yeah,
for me it will never be enough.
Um,
you know,
I have an obsession basically with power and money is power and you don't have a
platform without that.
So if you want to provide a positive message,
you need that power.
And without money you can't.
But that's not going to solve you and Nate problem of wanting more.
Now it's not.
And I,
and I accept it at the door and then it's like
you can say it about drugs.
One of the line you can sit about woman that you want another girl you can say
about anything that you have in a,
uh,
an obsession for abundance of,
right.
You're right.
So that's the,
not the problem,
but that's the,
the way the money borrowed is just the,
but that's okay.
I don't need,
I don't need to be okay.
I just need,
I need to be successful.
I need to make things happen.
Do that.
If you really feel that,
I'm not going to stop you obviously,
but I,
all I can tell you is my opinion,
and I can tell you this much,
is that it will never be enough.
And the feeling you have will never go away.
And anxiety,
we'll bring you in your life will never make you happy.
And then he calls us when he wants to commit suicide.
That's six you're going to get,
you're going to get worn out.
I'll tell you that's a dangerous sir.
But I do think though that people that get stuck in that totally over material
perspective,
that there was something missing inside and you might not see it,
that there might be a very big elaborate show and shiny things and beautiful
women.
But I think somebody that has immature behavior patterns like that,
I think it speaks to,
you know,
and an inner vacancy
I would say.
Awesome.
Um,
I just feel like I haven't reached,
um,
or I want to be,
uh,
financially happiness wise.
I'm not sure what I want to do all the time and
no,
I was there.
I'm sure he was the,
anybody was there.
Yeah.
Well you don't know where you're going.
I understand why I'm at where I'm at,
but I know he knows exactly what it is.
I know I'm sick,
I'm sick,
I'm sick.
He's on a,
on a mishit.
It does a beautiful thick,
that level of energy,
dedication,
focus.
Yeah.
That will attain mass loads of anything he puts his effort to.
I'm grateful where the
I am because every day I have been able to get up in the morning,
I'm alive.
There's certain situations,
rapes,
shootings,
everything out there that you know has occurred to me,
to other people and I'm blessed and I'm great to be alive because we don't know
when our time is going to be up.
That's hundred percent true.
Puts it in perspective right there.
I mean I think about where it came from,
things I take for granted now that I'd never would have imagined that a younger
age and but like you said,
the core blessing is to be alive.
A lot of people wake up with,
what am I going to eat?
Yeah,
what am I going to go?
What's this person going to try to do to me?
It's a fucked up,
excuse my French instead of mine.
So I'm extremely grateful that I'm on the giving side of things that I have the
ability to share and not take necessarily.
I have true friends and that I live a very,
very simple life.
And anyone who goes to my life and wants to stay in my life are very simple and
very loving at the same time.
I have nothing really to complain about besides the fact that I want to do more.
Um,
but even that is like a blessing yourself cause I have the opportunity to try it
and do those things
filling because of America.
But it's the best
the end of your life.
Are you a much more loving personally at the beginning of your life or you've
been at the end of this discussion?
I feel so.
I feel I've grown a lot and Laura,
she kind a privilege speaking with everyone.
We're here for the of the most important thing is love.
How much do you love at the end of your life compare to the beginning of your
life?
I think that's very true.
That's a,
that's the last question.
Thank you very much.
Thank [inaudible] hub you've got there.
What's up guys,
thank you for checking out that middle ground episode.
Hope you enjoyed it.
Um,
one thing you guys might not know is that the sponsor of the middle ground
series is a company called skillshare.
If you don't know,
skillshare is an online learning platform.
They've got so much that you can learn a,
they've got like 17,000 courses,
something like that.
Animation,
design,
motion graphics,
film editing.
So much.
Regardless,
you guys should check them out.
Um,
they got a link in the description below and the first thousand people that use
that link get two months free.
Just tell him the more I sent you.
Okay.